sometimes you just need a few extra
seconds before all the screaming and
stabbing starts up again from
nightmarish jump scares to unbelievably
weird-looking beasts these are the most
paused horror movie moments David
Kessler is having a rough vacation he
just wanted to go backpacking across the
Yorkshire Moors but the moment he steps
off the beaten path he's attacked by a
werewolf when he wakes up in a London
hospital he keeps having ghastly
nightmares these freaky dreams are the
scariest parts of an American Werewolf
in London
from the hospital we cut to David's home
he's working on his college homework his
family's watching TV and everything
seems peaceful before we can get our
bearings an army of mutant Nazi Monsters
burst into the house and guns down
David's family they burn his home shoot
everything to pieces and kill David and
that's when our hero wakes up in his
hospital bed it was all just a nasty
Nazi dream and his sympathetic nurse is
only too happy to open up the curtains
and let some sunlight in but as she
pulls back the shades there's a Nazi
beast standing there knife in hand and
he stabs the nurse to death we haven't
even seen the American werewolf yet and
we're already pressing pause so we can
collect our nerves the psycho witch
turned evil spirit Bathsheba is having a
great time in the conjuring terrorizing
the poor pairen family of course if
those kids think they're scared whenever
Bathsheba shows up then they've got no
idea what we're going through whether
she's playing hide and clap in the
cellar or getting all possessive
every time this hag shows up on screen
we're hiding behind the sofa of course
there's one Bathsheba seen that stands
head and shoulders above the rest it's
the scene where young Andrea hears
something banging around inside her
wardrobe nervous she goes to check it
out flings open the doors and finds
nothing inside that's because Beth Sheba
is up on top just waiting to pounce
horror fans will want to press the pause
button here for multiple reasons
one it's our first good look at the
demon haunting the parent family and she
is a terrifying sight to behold secondly
this is one of these scariest scenes in
movie history and when your heart rate
spikes to new and dangerous levels you
need to take a break and remind yourself
it's just a movie Wes Craven and Sam
Raimi are masters of the horror genre
and their films have a combined body
count higher than most serial killers in
addition to giving us some of the
scariest movies ever made Craven and
Raimi also had a friendly feud going on
where they'd reference each other's
movies in their own films for example in
the first Evil Dead a slashed up movie
poster for The Hills Have Eyes makes an
appearance Kraven returned the favor in
a Nightmare on Elm Street when Nancy
Thompson falls asleep watching Evil Dead
Raimi's well loved film makes another
appearance in the Craven directed scream
when one character considers watching
the undead action flick before deciding
against it as for Amy he absolutely
loves putting Freddy Krueger's glove
into his Deadite franchise not only did
it show up in an episode of ash vs. Evil
Dead but the deadly fashion accessory
also appears in Raimi's horror
masterpiece Evil Dead 2 eagle-eyed
horror fans should press pause when ash
Williams heads down into the fruit
cellar or walks into the woodshed the
glove shows up in both scenes hanging on
the wall in its razor blade glory now we
can't stop thinking about that Freddy
vs. Jason versus ash movie that we're
never going to get the Stephen King vest
seller Gerald's game seems like an
unfilmable book the plot follows a woman
named Jessie who retreats to a secluded
country house with her husband Gerald
where they hope to rekindle their
marriage unfortunately after cuffing his
wife to the bed
Gerald keels over from a heart attack
leaving his wife handcuffed to the bed
alone from there the novel pretty much
takes place inside Jessie's head somehow
director Mike Flanagan and actress carla
Gugino turned this crazy book into one
of the very best King at-at
of course that also means they had to
shoot the infamous degloving scene okay
visualize it then all of it now there
are horror movies that make you scream
and ones that make you want to throw up
the degloving seen from Gerald's game
will make you want to do both at once
desperate to get free especially since a
hungry dog and the creepy moonlight man
might return at any time
Jessie takes some serious steps to
escape her bonds she slits her wrists
with a piece of glass and then she just
starts yanking until the skin on her
hand starts peeling off she basically
turns her hand inside out to make her
great escape this gnarly scene sent
people into hysterics and once it's all
over the pause button will come in handy
as you proceed to lose your lunch it is
full of blink and you'll miss it moments
that require a pause button to fully
appreciate like the scene when Ben
Hanscom spends a day studying at the
library unfortunately things take an
unsettling turn when a librarian shows
up when she hands bend the book on local
history she shames him for staying
indoors during the summer but then just
ignores her a boy should be spending his
summer outside with friends don't you
have any friends I have the book now
however reading about dairy isn't a
relaxing way to spend your day the town
has a haunted history and Ben is
horrified to learn about a devastating
explosion that decapitated some poor kid
and sent his head Erling into a tree the
images are upsetting but the really
scary stuff is happening behind been
after the librarian leaves another
librarian who was previously shelving
volumes in the background before the
conversation stops what she's doing and
starts staring at Ben just before a
Pennywise starts appearing in the books
pages press pause and you'll see she's
grinning an evil grin and watching like
a predator about to devour its prey
obviously this means that Pennywise is
prowling
and the longer you look the more
goosebumps you get Mandy is an LSD
infused nightmare complete with Tigers
chainsaw battles and a posse of demon
bikers who look like they just rode out
of Hellraiser they're known as the black
skulls and they only loved two things in
this world drugs and pain there are
legends of these guys riding up and down
the interstate murdering truckers and
hitchhikers and these creatures share a
weird connection with a psycho cult
called the children of dawn if these
hippies ever need some muscle they just
blow a magical horn and the demons
appear ready to ride the first time the
black skulls roll onto the screen
shrouded by smoke and blood-red light
it's a moment to behold
much like the Cenobites the black skulls
each have their own grotesque look the
design for each biker is so unique that
we've got to press pause and marvel at
each one just for a moment or they're
unleashed on our poor heroes and things
get gory the perfection follows two
cellists who both attended the same
prestigious conservatory after meeting
for the first time they go on a road
trip across China however icky stuff
starts happening the moment they get on
the road
current superstar Lizzy comes down with
a mysterious flu and her new friend and
lover Charlotte does her best to help
Lizzy survive their nightmarish bus trip
as they wind deeper and deeper into the
Chinese mountains Lizzy starts throwing
up all over the place puking is bad
enough but when Charlotte takes a closer
look she sees that Lizzy's vomit is full
of maggots
even worse Lizzy's arm starts wriggling
like insects are literally crawling
under her skin it looks like she's
become some sort of bug incubator and
the insects are going to devour her arm
until Charlotte pulls a meat cleaver out
of her backpack and tells Lizzy to chop
off a limb when Lizzy pulls out that
meat cleaver we've got to hit pause so
we can figure out what the heck is going
on but hey don't worry things are going
to get way more bizarre before this film
is over she's got the traffic
this is your moment you can bow out
gracefully and I'll never hold it
against you the ritual follows four
friends who head into the Swedish woods
and encounter a pagan cult that worships
an ancient entity as it turns out that
entity really loves skewering people on
tree branches the monster is called the
yatin a beast out of Norse mythology and
for most of the film the giant creature
keeps out of sight it hides in the
forest plaguing our four heroes with
horrible nightmares before turning them
into shish kebabs eventually the
surviving backpackers are captured by
that after mentioned cult and unlucky
Dom is offered to the yatin as a
sacrifice up until this point we still
haven't seen the mysterious beast but
when Dom finally finds himself face to
face with the oversized creature it's
unlike anything we've ever seen before
the young ton has the body of a goat on
steroids the top half of its head looks
like a decapitated human torso with deer
antlers its glowing eyes are buried in a
cavern where its face should be and
there are long human-like arms hanging
off the sides of its head it's truly a
bizarre creature and we just have to
press pause and admire its wild design
unpopular ending aside signs is an
entertaining and terrifying sci-fi flick
and there are more than a few scenes in
this M night Shyamalan film that scared
us senseless but if we're talking about
paws worthy moments we all know exactly
what scene is going to make the list the
brazillian birthday party by this point
in the film it's pretty clear that
aliens are invading earth we've got crop
circles lights in the sky and chattering
voices on baby monitors but other than a
quick glimpse of a leg we haven't
actually seen an alien yet that all
changes when meryl turns on the news
not wanting to freak out his family he
moves the television into a coat closet
to follow the invasion on the news when
he sees a home video of a close
encounter Meryl loses his mind the
footage is shot on a camcorder lending a
disturbing realism to the scene a
Brazilian dad is filming his kids
birthday party but the children are
screaming and crying because there's
something awful outside the dad points
his camera into an alleyway suddenly the
alien lurches into view the
long limbs creature is only onscreen for
a second but it's enough to send shivers
down our spines we're pressing pause as
fast as we can because we need to
collect ourselves and to get a better
look at this ugly extraterrestrial home
invasion movies might be the scariest
sort of horror movie after all while
Freddy Krueger won't actually kill you
in your dreams
it's possible that a trio of real-world
mask-wearing psychos might drop by one
night to terrorize you just because
you're home that's the premise of The
Strangers chilling horror flick where a
couple are having one tough night even
before the strangers arrives when her
boyfriend runs to the store Kristen
finds herself home alone and feeling a
little unsettled the house is eerily
quiet and strangely empty and something
feels a little off almost like Kristen
is being watched and that's because
there's a masked killer standing in the
hallway just a few feet behind her the
villain stands in the door perfectly
happy to watch Kristen walk around the
house tracking her as she moves from one
side of the room to the other the whole
thing is done in one wide shot which
creates an unbearable sense of anxiety
the tension is so thick you could cut it
with a knife and things get so quietly
intense
we can't help but press pause check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one